uh good afternoon my name is mark
amaruso
i'm a tribeca resident i am representing
myself for the record but i'm also a
member of community board one
and also a member of the land mosque
committee that was referred to earlier
uh i didn't attend the landmarks
committee meeting because i didn't think
it would be an issue i was
shocked shocked that that our committee
actually voted not
to landmark this building you've
commissioners have gotten our
resolutions before
they read like little novels almost of
history
they're two three four pages and we'll
spend nauseam amount of time on arguing
about what the color of a trim should be
whether it's starkly correct or not but
this resolution
starts off like all our others you know
the history
many people have testified to it italian
renaissance it goes on and on and
praises it
then it says we
don't think the building should be
landmarked and the reason
is not really given but incredibly
and i've never seen this before i've
been 15 years on the board it requests
that
the historic facade be carefully
deconstructed
stored and incorporated into any future
designed for the site
now this to me is hypocrisy and
political correctness ideology to the
maximum
i mean it is just ridiculous on one hand
the people of the committee are
recognizing the fact
that there's historical significance
because they want to save the facade
but on the other hand they're saying
tear down the building
so what is it it's political correctness
also we're i would it's been mentioned
before and i respectfully
request that you keep the record open to
july 28th because you cannot give this
resolution any weight it has not been
passed by the full board yet
and there there will be debate public
comment on july 27th
so and i think as part of the city
charter that is required i'm not hundred
percent sure about that
thank you um in addition uh
everything has been mentioned about the
historical significance
and what would happen is that if you
don't
give this building landmark status every
other owner
of historic buildings will come in and
site this building
and say you didn't give park place 45
park place landmark status
why are you forcing me to have landmark
status i want to tear down the building
and build another 15-story tower
and they will say you're arbitrary and
capricious and you would probably be
sued because of that
and you've done it in the past you guys
know the history you guys
it's a wonderful commission we're losing
our history
and it's up to you guys to preserve it
that's the most important thing do not
allow political correctness
and elaine duck mayor and other
knucklehead politicians are only looking
to get reelected
influence you guys you've done a great
job in the past
and please continue to do that and
understand the historic significance of
this building
even though it's not the most beautiful
building but it does have historical
significance in its architecture
and its history thank you commissioner
thank you very much
rough is rafiq
haflori here then we're going to go on
pat
meehan oh there you go okay hi my name
is pat man
and i am here because i support landmark
designation of the building
but more importantly i'm here because i
think it's an affront
to all of the families that have lost
loved ones
at 9 11. that mrs regenhardt was here
there's other people that were here
and are still here and sometimes i wake
up and i wonder
what country am i living in is this
really america
is this what's going on where we have to
come here these people
were killed innocent people were killed
and we're here debating on whether
right in the near vicinity whether we
should put a mosque up
or not i mean there's a mosque there now
why does it have to be torn down and
built they can't even get uh the world
trade center
built and they're putting this place up
first and i think
personally i think bloomberg may have
bloomberg
is is not living in the real world
because there
are many many issues that are not
discussed regarding
uh imam faisal and his different uh
opinions that he says like saying that
we deserve it maybe in some way
i mean when when you signed in the front
desk if you wanted to speak
you know someone would tell you well
we're really not here to discuss
anything other than landmark decisions
but that's why
most people are here i mean let's face
it and in another thing i would like to
say thank you to hunter
and thank you to the media but how much
of the media coverage will you see
about this tonight but but
what about this guy here you think
you'll see him on
he'll be on and you notice how people
come and kneel down
they kneel down at you if you have an
opposing if you have an opposing opinion
so anyway i i really i feel
from my heart i hope you do the right
thing but could you just imagine being
one of these people not just the firemen
there were other people that would
innocently just murdered and killed
and we will not forget i live in pearl
river i am a born and bred new yorker
we lost many firemen many people from
canter
and it's just disgraceful i think what's
going on
so i hope you make the right decision
thank you very much for being here
okay more names john dash
john dash here uh sierra rose mazzola
is she here sierra rose mazzola
and then tamanna hai hye
please thank you
um i'm sierra rose i'm 19 years old
i'm a new yorker i've lived all over the
u.s throughout my life
i'm very tolerant of all types of people
all races all religions
i'm tolerant of them building mosques
even though
the religion that forced them to do what
they did on 9 11.
sorry i'm a little nervous to say this
there you go just put to put it down
just a little bit that's it
that's good i don't i don't want anybody
to think i'm intolerant
because i believe in what this country
stands for i believe in freedom
but i was there on june 6 at that
protest i saw how close this site is
this is not
right this is not right please don't do
this
don't do this there's so those people
were murdered
they were not just killed there were 3
000 of them they were murdered
because the people who believed those
things
they believed in the power of islam
allah akbar allah is great
that's right don't do this please don't
do this please please please don't do
this
i'm so nervous i have so much to say but
i'm so scared to say it
i don't want to be deemed intolerant of
anybody
i'm not intolerant of anybody but this
is not right
do the victims of the the families of 9
11 need to go down to 9 11 and hear
chants five times a day do they really
need that
no
do my sisters need to go down there to
see that i have two little sisters
see that mosque standing there they know
anybody who's an american knows
what caused these people to do this and
it's what they believe
it is what they believe in their hearts
and in their minds i'm not saying
everything in the quran is bad
there's a lot of beautiful things in
there but there's a lot of things
i forgot what it was no
okay sorry like i said i'm so nervous
just conclude uh your remarks that would
be nice thank you
please um
it's no mystery they they did this
because of what they believed folks they
did this because of what they believe
okay putting this mosque here is just
disrespectful please don't do it
please thank you very much thank you
then we have judy milo mr chairman i
think you
you called my name out earlier my name
is rafiq
qatwari okay i'm a long time
resident of new york city 40 years here
and i'm just going to pick up on things
that have been said in this hall
somebody mentioned
that the moderate muslims should step up
and speak up i am a moderate as well as
a radical muslim
i'm radical because i studied at
columbia university
i was taught by your some of the finest
professors over there and
i am moderate because
i like to drink beer
mr chairman
i want to thank you for giving me the
opportunity to
stand up here and speak up
i stand to oppose
landmark status for this building
is this mr mr chairman
i would like some respect when i'm
speaking please give me the floor
yes someone said someone said
this is america no you have the floor
let them have the floor please let me
have the floor
please proceed is this really about
landmarking
mr chairman i'm not running for office
and i don't have an axe to grind
is this really about landmarking or is
this
about taking the easy way out
and giving the building a landmark
status
because this has become this has
become in the media and this has been
made
by the by a very vocal minority
into a into an issue of bigotry
i think now somebody's calling me a
bigot back there and i guess that proves
my
point now
which is that i'm standing in a hall
that i'm ashamed to be an american today
please please which really
proves mr chairman the only thing we
have to fear
is fear itself because
of the people who are here
because can i please can i please
he needs the right to continue his
remarks can i please even if i have two
minutes
okay
this is america my time is not out
please ma'am you have to let him
continue his remarks
there's one person's already been let
out i don't want to do it this is the
chairman go ahead
mr chairman i was told that if i'm not a
citizen i should go home
which again proves my point please in
any case
i want to prove to this to this hall
that i indeed
am a citizen and if anyone has a doubt
this is my american passport
you can take a look at it man my middle
name is muhammad
okay now so
wind up if you can i will wind up mr
chairman i stand also
in memory of the hundred or so
bus boys and waiters who were murdered
on 9 11 which was a crime against
humanity i
was born in kashmir i'm an american
citizen
my heart is in kashmir my head is in
america
but i have a moral life my every one of
us has a moral life a moral conscience
please please mr chairman let him
continue and conclude i don't have to
say anything mr chairman
the point has been made on my behalf by
the bigots who are here thank you very
very much
okay judy milo's judy milo here
okay judy judy come please
judy milo will now speak it would be
nice
if people could
pay attention to the speaker and then
the woman
right behind judy will speak after she
has
please proceed so we can continue and
move through the hearing
it's very important to hear these views
please
okay i'm going to address uh mr tierney
yes okay
i'm i'm for landmark status of the
building
okay for a couple of reasons first
reason is i'm from queens
and i've seen what's been done to a lot
of one and two family houses in queens
before the zoning was changed developers
took over and they tore down a lot of
little houses and put up ugly
monstrosities
which a lot of people agree with they
they're
they take a small space and they go all
the way up
we're overcrowded with in our schools
we're overcrowded in the hospitals
we've got too many uh this is happening
too much i know they finally did change
the zoning
but to me the tearing down this building
and building something else not giving
it landmark
status is doing the same thing and i'm
tired of seeing it in my neighborhood
and everybody i know is tired of seeing
it and
i want to try to do something to stop it
from happening again
thank you i also want to make another
point about
um daniel badger and the gentleman that
designed this building
and uh he was a pioneer in ironworking
and i would like to say several of his
buildings that already have landmark
status
just briefly 287 broadway
105-107 chamber street 488
492 broadway 67 11th street
361 broadway 3442 west 14th street
all these buildings have landmark status
and that's because of the iron work
that he did and and it is an example of
it at
on this building also so um that is uh
where i'm
what i wanted to say all right thank you
very much thank you thank you very much
and wrote oh please ma'am
um good afternoon my name is tamanna hi
um
i am not a politician and nor do i
represent any islamic organization
nor do i belong to any islamic
fundamental
fundamentalist group i only represent
myself
and my faith i'm a muslim and i believe
the cordoba house should be approved
because it is an important symbol of
tolerance for new york city
please let her finish her remarks it's
not
fair for people
i'm a us citizen and i believe in
dialogue i believe in interfaith
communication
and if this building is not approved
as part of the cordoba initiative then
we new yorkers have shown that we care
more about politics than dialogue and
understanding
i apologize i'm very nervous i've never
spoken before and i i just wanted to say
that if this building
were converted into a hindu temple or a
church
i think very few people would claim that
it's a historical building
or sacred site
continue let her speak somebody just
said something very
helpful let her speak please
excuse me i'm sorry but just take a deep
breath and
i am an american and i am proud to live
here and i want to raise my children
here
my family is originally from india and i
plan never to go back there this is my
home
and i think we as americans and new
yorkers can take steps
to heal from the attacks of september
11th i haven't forgotten and i've heard
everybody else no one has forgotten
it's only been nine years ago but our
resilience
and our healing is uh is what makes this
country great
there's no other country like america
and that's why granting the approval of
the cordoba initiative should happen
because tolerance is much more
powerful than hatred
and i believe that this should not just
be a mosque but it should be an
interfaith center with the focus on
islamic understanding
that's that's what it should be i don't
agree with the fact that it should be a
mosque it should not just be a mosque it
should be a
center of islamic of uh interfaith
dialogue with islamic understanding
thank you sorry just one more one more
point
if imam faisal needs to be investigated
i support that too
i support all the members who are part
of this of the islamic faith
to be investigated if people want to
investigate me that's fine too
i'm i'm innocent i think that this is
very important that people
be investigated and i am a muslim and i
give you all the respect in the world
members who are here
members of the board and i think that
this
sorry if you could sorry and i just
wanted to say that
i have not forgotten 9 11 but i know
that we can
learn from each other and i think
there's a lot of hatred in this room and
uh it's very disappointing so please
members of the board please approve the
cordoba initiative
thank you thank you thank you very much
ann rotella
ann rotella here susan foreman
will be next please go ahead i bet
you first and then to my right yes hi
i'm ann rotella i have no
political aspirations i'm just here as a
new yorker
and um i think your job actually should
be so
easy just based on your um
job to handle landmark
issues not even all this political stuff
i
i think our town has has lost so many
buildings
uh to due to over development that issue
alone should
should move this up the table i don't
know why it's taken so many years
and it has become a political hot potato
because an
engine fell on it has everyone lost
sight of that
so if we are trying to look at this
building as something special
we should have we forgotten what
happened
i mean i think it's kind of outrageous
that you can't separate it
and that some of you aren't even looking
at me when i'm talking
it's outrageous this is such a real
serious issue for our our city
let's not forget it it's very serious
and we don't want to appear intolerant
well then let the
tolerant mainstream muslims understand
us and speak up and say maybe this is
too
soon let's try and work together maybe
it's too
soon to do this here on this site
and then maybe we can heal but we're not
going to heal
unless there's so much silence on the
part
of the mainstream muslim community let's
work together
let's not forget thank you very much
over to my right now please hi my name
is marion dreyfuss
i am an immigrant who has become a
citizen
i uh was in north africa
for a month and every day that i was
there
in two three three countries i heard
songs
dedicated to cordoba now this was six
seven hundred years ago and the people
in tunisia and algeria and other
countries in north africa
still mourn the loss of spain
and cordoba which represents the
conquering
of christian faith at that time
and we are to be understanding that
something called the cordoba
institute or initiative represents
healing and interfaith dialogue it does
not
it represents the re-taking over of
something that was lost to them
700 years ago and if we
are still mourning the loss of 3 000
plus
people and the children they might have
had the children they might have had and
we'll never have
if we are losing them and we are still
mourning them from 10 years ago
and we see people who are trying to
initiate this cordoba
building edifice uh monstrosity which
loses the sanctity of the dead people
that we lost
ten years ago how can we then how can we
say
that we should forgive and forget when
six seven hundred years ago
they have not forgotten the loss of what
they took over
in violence and murder and mayhem
and i i just think the parallels are
very ironic
and they say that extinction
animal husbanders say extinction is
forever
when you lose an animal genre it is
gone forever now we are
saying that the people who are dead
uh should not be remembered we are
saying that this building
that is not lovely it is maybe not
lovely but it is an
important element of new york's history
this building ought to be landmarks
not because it's lovely but because it
has many of the earmarks
that make other buildings appropriate
for landmarking status
and we do not love our children or other
people because they are lovely
but because they are innately worthwhile
and this building
too is innately worthwhile in addition
to in sanctity and its status
as a representative of something that
stood
on that day 9 11 when many people died
because of the actions of a few thank
you thank you very much
please good afternoon
um i'm a native-born new yorker i've
lived here all my life naturally
i've uh state your name if you want my
name is susan
forman okay thank you i've um live in
this neighborhood
i've seen building after building be
torn down
with architectural meaning and
significance
and beauty i'm asking you to stop
tearing down buildings of 100 150 years
old
especially this one we have i've seen
churches go down i was
i remember penn station going down a
magnificent magnificent building
you could cry looking at it uh
took four years to tear it down that's
how beautiful it was
well-built it was take this opportunity
do what your job is to save more
buildings especially with this
historical
significance and sensitivity that
has grown around it um
i i'm too emotional about it just
please do your job i beg you save this
building it is a landmark
thank you very much elise uh i've been
here what you are discussing
but i am getting up as a family member
to plead with you
to have respect for who we've lost i
lost my son that day
and this is so disrespectful to all of
their memories
to have a mosque so close to what we
consider holy ground
is disgraceful and i'm embarrassed as a
new yorker that you are even considering
this
after what our state in our city has
gone through
after what's happened not just to us who
are family members
the country as a nation we suffered
tremendously i've spoken to people all
over the country and they
tell me who they what they were doing
that day everyone remembers that just as
we remember where we were when kennedy
was killed
how in heaven's name can you permit this
to happen
when this is so painful to all of us
they can have a mosque anywhere in the
city but i beg you not to let them
construct it
so close to where our loved ones are
thank you thank you very much
good afternoon chair tierney and members
of the august commission
of the landmarks preservation commission
my name is joseph g
garber uh i am uh the
director of the civil service merit
council a good government group
that represented unfortunately many of
the first responders who are no longer
with us
i'm also a member of the 90th priest and
community council psa 3 resident police
council
and community board born in williamsburg
public safety committee and most
recently
i was the the highest ranking executive
board member of the citizens police
academy alumni association
i'm 100 full landmarking this building
i'm also 100 against building a mosque
on this area or anywhere close no matter
how pro-america
the current demons are we cannot project
what's going to happen
in the future you have iman's they
change just as in the book of esther
when a new king arose and did not know
the jewish people
and also in egypt and there arose a new
king pharaoh
okay so number one we do not know what's
going to happen and the new
iman may not be able to keep out muslims
who are
pro-american jihad so therefore i say no
no no
i respectfully disagree with my friends
commissioner kelly
and mayor bloomberg that a mosque on the
low east side
is not good it's a clear and present
danger i'd like to memorialize
some of my friends who died in 9 11.
deputy
chief and fountain of the pod authority
police inspector romero port authority
police
captain manzy port authority police
inspector richard winter nypd
uh first deputy fire commissioner jimmy
feehan
father judge ny nyfd uh chief genghi
and uh father and captain terry hatton
it was rudy giuliani's
secretary's husband and the 30 23 nypd
and 67 port authority employees made it
all rested
in internal please and peace please
landmark 45 parkways thank you
thank you thank you very much
someone else uh let me call those names
again
or more names lisa francik robert
conlon moore peter davies
peter davies md
s o mds please come to the mic
yeah what's your name or your name for
the record
my name is peter davies i just want to
focus
more on the historical early historical
aspects of 45 47 park place
up until you may know this but it hasn't
been uh brought up
uh up until about 1850 this property was
part of columbia college
that stretch of park place was not cut
through
until about 1850 and
apparently when
this property was transferred over to
new ownership
this was one of the first buildings that
was uh built
on the on the new park place there are
photographs
showing the cutting through of park
place from those early
years i i'm not here to tell you to say
one way or the other which if you should
landmark this property or not i'm just
bringing some
historical perspective most likely the
foundations
because of the way buildings were built
back then
of the original columbia college
buildings probably still exist
if you look at the maps of that time the
way that park place was cut through
the you can actually see that this
building
probably rose from uh across where the
original columbia college buildings were
um it should also be pointed out that
i think you all are being given a little
according a little too much
power beyond what you have today in
terms of this site
if this building were landmarked there
are zoning
issues that would allow the blot next
door
at 49.51 to be built upon without
anything
that landmarks can do so the owner is
free
to build upon that portion of the lot as
they see fit
and the far for the 47-45-47
does allow building up
a vertical enlargement on the existing
property if it were
to be landmarked so the owner would have
the ability to
use the existing building and build
up as he sees fit in accordance with
zoning
so um just wanted to bring those things
up good luck
thank you thank you for being here mds
dreyfus
i have on this sign-in sheet
and
gary bernard fenard not sure
p-h-a-n-r-a-r-d
wilton avalano wilton avalano
please
and then ant while you're coming up if
anthony williamson or jacqueline
crochet are here they should go to the
other mic thank you
okay please
it's okay thanks hi my name is wilton
erliano i'm
currently a student and i'm an american
citizen but
i was born in the middle east i was born
in the country of oman
i came here when i was very young so i
have
pieces of other cultures inside of me
that
i'm bringing here to america i'm
filipino myself i'm not um
i'm not of military certain descent but
as a visitor
that has been adopted by this country
i'm
very proud to say that i love america
and what i stand for today i'm just
navigating myself into this
issue recently but what i stand for
today is transparency between both sides
that
i would like to hear from the people
that are putting up this
this uh this site this mosque
uh what their true intents are and uh
just hearing before them editing the
site just to make it more publicly
appealing
that's not what i also support the
interfaith idea and about islamic
awareness
that seems more appropriate but
i feel like any muslim that would want
to speak in this room would be scared
and that's really unfortunate i was
hoping
i hoped walking to this room this is the
first time for me in a setting like this
that
there would be people here ready to
listen ready to hear all sides ready to
know the where the other person come
from and i know that you are
but um i guess our passions get the best
of us but uh
i'm just speaking as someone that has
been adopted by this country that
um let's please hear the other side
before just cutting it off
and i'm just hoping for their
willingness to do the same
thank you thank you very much thomas
ognabini
is here representing um carl palladino
but please you proceed while mr agnevani
comes forward go ahead good afternoon
thank you very much mr chairman
members of the landmark committee my
name is anthony williamson and i
represent the construction and general
building laborers
local 79 mission tenders of new york
city
we had a lot of members who participated
in the
9 11 tragedy but i want to
focus primarily
on the fact that community board one and
would like
also this committee and concern people
to take note that
irresponsible development or in
any development it's important that we
have responsible
contractors and parties involved in the
redevelopment
and for some reason or unknown reasons
we haven't heard who exactly is going to
be developing this project
are we going to have engineers coming
from outside of this country
or are we going to be using the skills
and talent that we've got
right here in the united states to
develop
four to five power plays these are the
questions i would like to ask the
developer
because i made phone calls and reached
out to
the developer but no one maybe because
of time
timeline limits or there are other you
know
factors did not return any call to
me or anyone who are involved in the
construction industry
i would like to ask these questions did
anyone
from that organization reach out to the
building and construction trades
and seek advice on how we're going to go
about the redevelopment of that project
if we as americans we would like to see
that structure develop
in a responsible manner with labor
standards
we're talking about union jobs and
nothing below the standards of the
workers
who are right now participating in the
redevelopment of ground zero
you must bear that clearly in mind
whatever is the final outcome of this
project
i stand there and we will fight to
ensure
that the redevelopment have labor
standards
and every person that in on that job
be treated with dignity and respect
that's why i'm standing here as an
american
because of the freedom i enjoy that's
why i'm standing here
and because of the bravery of which we
stand for
thank you thank you very much thomas
ognavini